There will be a little bit of deja vu as you see my slides, but I think we'll have the
opportunity to dive a little bit more deeply into the trial data.
So I'll be presenting the initial results of Bexobrutidig, and I also struggle to say
the word, the NERCS degrader that's far along in clinical development.
Admittedly, I have not yet treated a patient with this drug.
Our site will join their trials going forward, but I have the opportunity to review their
data from ASH.
So this is the molecule, not as a medicinal chemist, I can't say too much, but I sometimes
feel like anything with the same number of circles and nitrogens will bind similarly.
But the basic idea that one side of it binds to serum line, the other side of it binds
to BTK, and I believe in the ATP binding pocket domain of the BTK molecule.
I'm not going to address some of these, but I guess the things that they highlight are
that this is...
Sorry.
This is something that acts catalytically, so not much of the molecule is needed to maintain
activity.
It has been confirmed to cross blood-brain barrier is the other thing that's sometimes
highlighted in its preclinical testing.
This is the phase one trial design.
So phase one A was a dose escalation ranging from 50 to 600 milligrams with a cohort specifically
in CLL-SLL and a Waldenstrom's or non-Hodgkin lymphoma cohort.
And then a phase one B that was initially based on project optimist testing.
200 milligram and 600 milligram dose levels, and then 600 milligram dose expansion cohorts
in various specific clinical contexts, including no mutation or triple refractive disease and
others, or double refractive disease and others.
I'll focus just on the CLL data for this presentation, although I've seen that the Waldenstrom's
data has been presented in other contexts and looks very promising as well.
So for the patients with CLL, you can see on the left, the 48 patients.
Treated in the dose escalation included 16 patients treated at that 600 milligram dose.
About a third of them stopped treatment for various reasons, mostly progression, if you
total up the numbers, and just a few, four of the 22 stopped for adverse event.
In the phase one B cohort, you can see, I guess, a total of 54 patients treated in the
200 or 600 milligram doses across the different cohorts.
Again,
about a third stopping mostly for progression, and a few for adverse events.
The median follow-up is longer for the phase one A, so a lot of the progression-free survival data
focuses in that cohort. Dr. Erdat presented this, but I think the other thing to highlight is they
did allow patients with CNS involvement in the trial, and they do document responses in that
group, which I thought was interesting. The adverse events are shown here, and similar to what
Dr. Erdat said, I think adverse event-wise, I would view this as another BTK inhibitor.
The AEs are largely overlapping with what we're familiar with seeing with BTK inhibitors, maybe
confirming the specificity of its effects. They did have a few grade five events that they all
deemed as not related to the drug, pulmonary embolism, pneumonia, and death for reasons
not specified. And then, as Dr. Erdat showed, excellent activity across different mutational
characteristics. The overall PFS is, or the median PFS at the moment is, or median duration
response is 20 months. But again, this is at the phase one A cohort, so including patients treated
at lower than the recommended phase two dose. And the phase one A PFS is shown here in Kaplan-Meier
form. Subgroup analyses, as Herb showed, are here. I think that the one thing that,
maybe to highlight, are that the C481S mutations all uniformly responded. You can see nine out of
nine. They had a few patients with other mutations that are shown here with, I guess, less uniform
response. They did not have patients with the A428 mutation, which I think has been identified
as a concerning mutation for this class of drugs. So the conclusions that the authors drew,
and then my thoughts on their further development are shown here. High response rate with
so far, pretty meaningful PFS for a group of patients that may not have other treatment options.
So where do we go forward as a field? I'd say both of these drugs are, you'll hear from other
speakers, are next looking at comparisons to pertobrutinum as far as their registrational
strategies. I think where they'll be most useful to us as physicians and the patients are to
confirm that they work in highly refractory or "triple exposed" cases, where this will be really
important. And then the other thought I had is how was this drug, or how are the two drugs going
to differentiate from each other? Are they just two ways of degrading BTK? Over time, we'll be
learning that there are some small distinctions, perhaps as we saw between the different covalent
BTK inhibitors. But yeah, it will be interesting for the field. I do think right now it's helpful
for both of these drugs to be in development so that patients across the country have option to
this class of drugs. And then the other thought I had is how was this drug going to differentiate
from each other? And I think it would also be helpful for all of us to have perhaps some
firsthand experience treating patients with both these drugs, so we can start to differentiate them
in our experience as well. Thanks so much. Dr. Andy Roark: